this is certainly a curious case and one
which could depending on how it
progresses result in Prince Harry being
kicked out of America it all centers
around what the Duke of Sussex wrote on
his U.S visa form when he applied for
the Visa allowing him to move here to
America in March 2020. in his Netflix
series and his book spare the prince
admitted to having used cocaine
marijuana and magic mushrooms under U.S
law admission of or evidence of past
drug use can be grounds to reject a Visa
there are two key questions on a U.S
visa form first have you ever been a
drug abuser or addict and second have
you ever violated any Law related to
Controlled Substances so the question at
the heart of this court case is what
answers did Harry give now why is it in
court at all well because the prince
finds himself being used as the perfect
case study in a case trying to prove
that the U.S department for homeless
Security Homeland Security is acting
improperly by granting visas to people
who should not be eligible for them the
case is being brought by a conservative
us-based think tank the Heritage
Foundation it's pursuing the US
government to find out if it's acting
according to procedure when granting
visas essentially the prince is caught
up in a bigger battle between a
conservative owner organization and the
Biden Administration as part of the
evidence for the case lawyers for the
Heritage Foundation are pointing to
other celebrities like Nigella Lawson
Pete Dougherty others too who have in
the past been denied visas for previous
drug use the hearing could last weeks if
the judge allows the the prince's visa
application to be published if it's in
the public interest then we will find
out either if Harry lied and said he had
never taken drugs or admitted taking
them and that the U.S government allowed
him in anyway either way it will call
his presence here into question